I want to talk about another angle to
this and then we're gonna move on from
the Trump and word tapes Fiasco with
every passing day almost with every
passing few hours we get closer to
confirming that Omarosa Manigault rump
is recorded saying horrible vile
disgusting things about black people
during tapings of The Apprentice is real
so we had number one the fact that
Omarosa claims Trump regularly used the
n-word and it's on tape to trump claim
that it's all lies and then three we had
this recording released where three
black Trump staffers appear to be
describing or discussing or debating how
to spin and provide context for
something really bad that Trump said we
then have as I told you just minutes ago
the press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders unwilling to deny that it's
possible Trump is on tape using the
n-word about black people and we now
have sort of like a fifth or sixth piece
to this entire fiasco which is an
interview with Penn Jillette Penn
Jillette of Penn & Teller Fame I guess
they are the illusionist magicians I
don't know what word they use what's
what's some political commentary thrown
in there yeah political magicians I
don't know why or you want to call him
Penn Jillette was a contestant on The
Apprentice the reality show Trump hosted
five years ago and he also now is saying
Trump would regularly say absolutely
horrible things during tapings and the
interview was published yesterday in
vulture and it's really bad and there's
a couple key parts that I'm going to
read to you one is where he is asked
does Mark Burnett have tapes of
President Trump saying damaging things
during Celebrity Apprentice and pence
says yeah I was in the room and when
he's asked can you tell me what you've
heard him say Penn said quote no if
Donald Trump could not become president
I would tell you all the stories but the
stakes are now high and I am an
unreliable narrator what I do as much as
anything as I'm a storyteller and story
tellers are liars so I can emotionally
tell you things that happened racially
sexually and that showed stupidity and
lack of compassion when I was in the
room with Donald Trump and I guarantee
you that I will get details wrong I
would not feel comfortable talking about
what I felt I saw in that room because
when I was on that show I was sleeping
four to five hours a night I was
uncomfortable stress is the wrong word
but I
not at my best then at the end of the
day they put you in a room and they
bring out a guy Trump who has no power
whatsoever
and he's capricious and petty he is
actually being upfront here which is
yeah he said this stuff but I might not
get every detail right and the trumpets
would latch on to any minor
insignificant detail I get wrong to try
to discredit the entire story I've never
been a big fan of Penn Jillette's in any
way I've never found his commentary
super interesting I've never really
cared for his act but I don't want to
cloud that I don't want to let that
cloud the reality that he's being very
precise he's been cautious here about
what he says and what he doesn't say and
I think big picture he's a force for
good here he's a force in favor of the
world of skepticism and he's done some
good things and I have no reason
whatsoever to think that he's being
dishonest here yeah I think he's right
here because human memory can get muddy
too right especially because this
happened several years ago sure that's
why you know like eyewitness accounts
aren't the best pieces of evidence but
it's also not a denial - he's not saying
that Trump never used the word
no and he is saying that the horrible
things were related to both race and
sexuality so that is once again sort of
along the lines of what Omarosa is
saying but let's cut through all of this
right cut through Penn's assertions cut
through the speculation and the
conjecture and let's get down to what
matters if we ultimately get audio of
Donald Trump throwing the N word around
would it make a difference he said
racially insensitive stuff the entire
campaign he made fun of disabled people
he slammed the parents of dead military
service members he talked about his own
penis size during debates he talked
about grabbing him by the [ __ ] and
assaulting women by using his celebrity
power and he won anyway right people
already voted for him despite his
regularly saying horrible things is it
really actually going to change anything
if there's an word tapes of Trump I
don't think so I don't think so either I
mean in an alternate universe where
Bernie Sanders is president and there's
a tape of him saying the n-word yeah
that could take him down into his
resignation but with Trump there's
already a track record of racism like
it's already baked in we already know
who Trump is yeah but Trump was a
Democrat when he
those things I can't say it with a
straight face
last thing prepare for Penn Jillette to
be attacked to some wacky left-wing
liberal he's not he's a longtime small
government libertarian he's associated
with the right-wing libertarian Cato
Institute he's no liberal they might try
to smear him as one but he's not and the
last and most important thing to
consider why would mark burnett the
producer of The Apprentice if he has
these tapes not have release them I
can't think of any good answers other
than he knows or suspected that they
would have been damaging to Trump and he
wanted to protect Trump and that's
something that should scare us all
because I believe that it would be his
responsibility if he had these
recordings to put them out there if
there was a time to release them it
would have been in the heat of the 2016
election cycle it may be shortly after
the Access Hollywood tapes but we I
don't know what his politics are at the
same time you know the best time to
plant the tree is 20 years ago
the second best time is today the best
time to release him would have been
before Trump was elected the next best
time is right now and I hope that he
does that if he's got him I'm on Twitter
at Dee Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show fantastic program for
you today and I'm glad you're with us
I'm pleased to tell you that today's
show is underwritten by better help.com
slash Pakman therapy is important we
have a real crisis in our country not
just people who could benefit from
mental health services but the stigma
that surrounds mental health services
and as many people in the audience know
lots of people in my family work in the
field of mental health and I have made
it a mission of the show to at any
opportunity make clear that there is
absolutely no shame whatsoever in going
to talk to someone when you feel that
that's the right thing to do and that's
what better help provides you get a
fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
videophone and text it's less expensive
than meeting in person with a counselor
after three months the price goes down
even more but you get the same
professional service that you would from
going into somebody's office and you
also get unlimited access you
can speak to a counselor every day if
you want signing up is easy you go to
better help calm / Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will pair you with a
therapist that works for you but you're
always able to switch to somebody else
if there's a better fit available go to
better help calm / Pakman it's so easy
to sign up and get started we're putting
a link in the description if you're
watching this on YouTube it is better
help calm a /pa que ma n